Petyr Baelish: From the east coast of the Vale,
the Fingers reach out into the Narrow Sea,
four rocky peninsulas plagued by wind and rain,
and barren to all but the hardiest of weeds.
The ancestral home of House Baelish.
Our house began with my great-grandfather,
a Braavosi sellsword who came to the Vale at the
invitation of House Corbray. My grandfather raised
himself to the status of hedge knight and even
managed to acquire a bit of land and a keep on
the smallest of the Fingers, though I do believe
he missed sleeping under his titular hedges.
The only thing worse than owning
a dreary and desolate land
is owning only a small portion of it. Luckily,
I didn't spend much time there as a child.
During the War of the Ninepenny Kings
(a cheap name for a cheap cause),
while other men fought for the king, my
father fought to befriend Hoster Tully,
Lord Paramount of the Trident and head of one
of the oldest and greatest Houses in Westeros.
Thanks to my father's heroic efforts, Lord
Hoster agreed to foster me at Riverrun
with his own children. Until then, my
whole world had been a small tower on
the gull-stained rocks of the Fingers.
But when I first saw the stone walls of
Riverrun rising from the Trident, towering over me
(back then I was a little more easily impressed),
the boy in me thought the gods
themselves must live in such a place.
I soon learned otherwise. Lord Tully's
son, Edmure, was quick to ensure I would
never forget myself in their House.
He nicknamed me "Littlefinger," after
my size and homeland, and the name
was just cruel enough to stick.
His sisters, Lysa and Catelyn, made me a pawn in
their kissing-game, traded back and forth between
them for practice. Needless to say, I enjoyed
spending time with them more than Edmure. As we
grew older, the game began to change, as all games
do. Lysa grew more bold and Cat more demure.
When Lord Tully announced Cat's betrothal to
a brute from the North, whom she'd never met,
I realized her duty would outweigh
any feelings she had for me.
Fool that I was, I challenged this Brandon Stark
to a duel for her hand. He was a warrior. I was
a boy. If Cat had not intervened, he would
have killed me and laughed over my corpse.
For my insolence, Lord Tully banished me from
Riverrun. No matter. I had learned everything by
then. I would fight my battles not with swords,
but with wits, as few men could match me.
Even then, House Baelish might have died out on
the rocks of the Fingers. I was again a poor lord,
with no allies and no prospects except, if he
were lucky, a daughter of a middling merchant.
Then, opportunity arose. The Mad King executed
that Brandon Stark and incited a rebellion.
My old "friend," Lysa Tully, was married off
to Jon Arryn, Lord of the Vale, to cement
the alliance against the Iron Throne.
Bringing her within my circle again, I
quickly capitalized on our former "affection" and
persuaded her to have me appointed as controller
of customs at Gulltown, the Vale's greatest port.
Wars burn gold like wildfire. When I increased the
port's income tenfold, her husband took notice
of this lowly lord from the Fingers. And when the
new and profligate King Robert needed a Master of
Coin who could find gold where no one else could,
why, Lord Arryn knew just the man.
Sandor Clegane: Honor. Glory. Lies to
make idiot boys want knighthood, and
idiot girls spread their legs for it.
Let me tell you what makes a knight:
killing. Either enough men, or the right man.
House Clegane should know.
We're very good at both.
Most families claim some great ancestors so
far back that nobody can prove them liars.
Not us. My grandfather kept the
kennel for Lord Tytos Lannister
of Casterly Rock, the father of Lord Tywin.
Lord Tytos was a weak man who didn't know it.
One day while hunting, he stumbled on a lioness.
Instead of embracing the man who wore her on his
banners, she tried to tear out his throat.
Lucky my grandfather came up with the dogs
and drove the big cat away.
As a reward, the Cleganes got lands and a keep and
a son to squire for the Lannisters. We took the
three hounds who died for them as our new sigil.
When Tywin Lannister became Lord of Casterly Rock,
he wanted more from his former kennelmaster than
fealty. He bet that training hounds to kill
isn't far from training boys to kill. In just
two generations, my brother Gregor and I proved
him right. I gutted my first man at twelve.
Years after, servants started disappearing in
our keep, and even a sister I don't remember.
But nobody could prove anything against
Gregor or dared if they caught him at it.
For my father wanted a knight in our family
and thought he’d found one in Gregor,
who at thirteen towered over enough men
that they called him "the Mountain."
Sure, Gregor looks quite the
champion from a distance,
but a mountain can't cleave
a man in half in one blow,
and won't break a wench's face if she talks.
Through Lord Tywin's influence, Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen kindly anointed my brother personally.
A great honor for our family, everyone said.
One year later, Ser Gregor chivalrously sacked
the Prince's city, brained the Prince's baby,
and murdered the Prince's wife, winning our family
yet more honor from the new king and queen.
Soon after, my father died,
they say, in a hunting accident.
The same day that Gregor became lord of the
Clegane lands, gold, and anything under his roof,
I left our home to take service at Casterly Rock.
Lord Tywin is not like his father. Neither is King
Joffrey or the likes of me would never be on
the Kingsguard, with all those "true knights."
Between them, the man who serves the
Lannisters will never lack for killing.
I'll guard this king, such as he is. Gregor
will kill the other ones, such as he does.
When we're done, we’ll see how many people
still believe in songs and fairytales.
Jon Snow:Where House Reed holds the gate to
the North, House Manderly holds the port.
White Harbor, the closest thing to a southern
city we have governed by the closest thing to
a southern family we have. Generations ago, the
Manderlys were driven from the Reach, but the
Starks gave them their land in return for fealty.
Now White Harbor is the richest city of the North,
and the Manderlys the richest family. Not in
gold and silver like their southern counterparts,
but in fish and grain and trade.
As for the other great Northern houses,
the Starks brought them into the
fold during the Age of Heroes.
A Stark wrestled an ironborn for Bear
Island and gave it to the Mormonts.
A Stark granted a keep and land to a younger son,
Karlon, in return for putting down a rebellion.
His family then grew up into the Karstarks.
Starks fought the wildlings and their
Kings-Beyond-the-Wall beside the Umbers
of Last Hearth, thus earning their fealty.
Boltons. Back then, they were the bane of the
North. A few were even rumored to wear their
enemies' flayed skins as cloaks. But after
centuries of war, they too bent the knee.
Sansa Stark: Rodrik Stark wrestled an Ironborn
lord for Bear Island and granted
it to House Mormont when he won.
A younger son of our family, Karlon
Stark, won his own keep after he put
down a rebellion and founded House Karstark,
one of the most powerful in the North.
When the Manderlys were exiled from the Reach,
my ancestors shielded them and gave them a home
at the mouth of the White Knife in return for
holding the river against pirates and invaders.
Now they're one of the
wealthiest houses in the North.
I'm not so naive to pretend that the
entire North welcomed Stark rule.
The last Warg King was slain at Sea Dragon
Point along with all his sons and beasts.
The last Marsh King died at the hands of
King Rickard Stark, and House Reed has
held the swamps of the Neck ever since.
Houses Greenwood, Towers, Amber, Frost.
None survive today as more
than names in dusty old books.
But my ancestors never wanted to destroy their
foes root and stem. The Umbers of Last Hearth
and the Glovers of Deepwood Motte bent the
knee and became loyal vassals of House Stark.
The Red Kings of House Bolton wore cloaks made
from the skins of Stark princes they'd flayed,
and one of the Boltons was even known as the
Redarm because he liked to plunge an arm into
the bellies of captive Starks and pull out their
entrails with his bare hand. The North deserved
to be wiped clean of them. Yet my ancestors spared
them after their defeat because they believed the
North couldn't afford to fight itself any longer.
Time soon proved them right. When the Andals
swept into Westeros, they obliterated all the
kingdoms of the First Men except the North.
Each of the southern kingdoms fought the invaders
on its own, but the North fought as one.
When the Andals tried to sail on the White
Knife, the Manderlys fell on their ships.
When the Andals tried to march an army through
the Neck, the Reeds fell on their soldiers.